the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
hello and welcome to our broadcast of
the 2023 spring chess classic my name is
Julian perlaco and I'm joined by women's
Grandmaster Tata valbrahamian and
hopefully we'll have another exciting
day of Chess ahead of us hello everyone
and welcome yesterday was a great day of
Chess as we saw some very interesting
battles on the game that we're really
interested in was this game by Benjamin
Bach where he ended up winning in a
really beautiful fashion of domination
of picture versus night and very much
looking forward to looking through the
games today and before we get started
let's take a look at the standings and
see where we are and in group a we have
a three-way tie for first place between
Darius Suites Christopher you and Yasser
quesada and we have a half with half a
point behind we have a pack of players
some Savion ilionic Benjamin gladura
Daniel Darda and Benjamin buck and in
group be we had a soul leader but
actually Chandra and Felix blauberger
right now are tied for first place and
we have gargelly Contour Jason Leon who
won his game chasing the players with
half a point and at 50 percent we have
three players Victor michalevski
tambasaurian batsurin and Luca put the
Buddhists of Leverage so let's go ahead
and look at the tournament format they
are playing game in 90 for a game in 90
with a 30 second increment for the first
40 moves and after move 40 they will get
30 minutes for the rest of the game with
of course a 30 second incumbent
throughout the entire game
and the schedule is they will be playing
every day with no rest days at 1 pm
Central Standard time we will be live
with you three hours after the start of
the game every day until the end of the
tournament and before we start looking
at the game so let's take a look at the
pairings and see what we have in store
for today so are there any games you're
looking forward to looking at today well
I'm definitely interested in the
Christopher you game of course they're
uh Daria Schwartz is a leader I believe
Christopher is uh you is as well and um
every day Christopher is just looking
for a fight so that's definitely going
to be interesting I think so that is our
matchup of the day so let's start with
that game and another game that I wanted
to look at right after is the Benjamin
Bot game but let's start with this one
and immediately we see that black is up
upon and the question is where is
White's compensation
well that is a good question yeah
I guess uh White has a compensation in
the form of the bishop against Knight
but uh it's not it's not great
compensation uh I guess so why do you
say it's not a great conversation
because we talk about this um
the long-term potential of the bishop
every day but here right immediately
like no so I think the difference is in
most positions there are pawns on both
sides and in this case there are pawns
all on the same side so it's harder to
exploit the speed of the bishop versus
the Knight but
um yeah I mean I I think that white is
better off having a bishop than not
having a bishop if this is why why it's
not just lost I guess it's having the
bishop on C6 usually it is very strong
which looks like a Catalan Bishop I
think this came from a Catalan um it's
unfortunately here it's aiming at
nothing usually it aims at a bishop at
the pawn on B7 but here we see that this
bishop is this on this long diagonal but
there is nothing on the diagonal for it
to be eyeing or attacking so maybe
temporarily there's this looseness for
the Knight but immediately black can
connect this Knights and the piece is
really well placed on
D5 so I think
um White's way to fight here try to
trade everything and go into four four
versus three end game which is an
interesting way of looking at things
because usually when we're done material
the rule is don't trade but here if I
was able to just take everything off the
board and just leave a rook for each
side then white should be able to draw
that position but with pieces on the
board and
especially as this bishop gets stuck on
this side of the board maybe I can't
even dream about of bringing my pieces
to this side let's take a look and see
how we got here
so we did see this position in the world
championship game today
with H3 but H3 wasn't played
and G3 so we do have a Catalan with this
bishop before check and A5 I believe
this was the game that michalevsky
played and he said he wasn't ready for
A5
but he ended up winning that game in the
first round yeah these lines can become
very sharp and also they can become very
positional sort of like Black's choice
you can play lines with B5 instead of B6
I think B6 is a more calm approach but
these B5 positions can get a little wild
after A4 C6 and black tries to keep the
material but white does have a lot of
compensation for his missing Pawn
in the game B6 was played with the idea
of defending the wizard from this side
and plug saves the pawn anyways because
the plug doesn't save the pawn then it's
just too many concessions right because
I just get the center I get the pawn
back white will just get everything
they ever wanted yeah I think it might
be worth pointing out if um white were
the castle instead of playing the move
A3
um I think black's point was if Queen C4
then black has this bishop A6 idea which
is a thematic and a lot of Catalan
positions
me too is hanging
but in the game A3 was played so the
bishops come off so B5 black has to hang
on to this pawn and then uh Black's main
idea is to just hang on to this pawn and
claim that they have a pawn for this bad
Bishop that they're going to so I guess
to endure some kind of suffering in this
position because white will have a nice
Center and there's this problem of the
C8 bishop and lack of space but a pawn
is a pawn and a lot of times
blood can just stay up upon so B3 is
played
and then the problem is with this C5
Square
so castles Bishop A6 a takes B5 that's
an interesting decision
yeah I
um these sorts of positions I've seen
these sorts of positions maybe from
different lines but I think uh White
typically tries to just play with
knights on E5 and C5 without changing
the structure and hope that black takes
on A4 and you can play against the C6
and A5 Pawns
so a takes B5 is
um I guess very concrete
he will also as we will see in the game
he plays A4 so we have a bishop between
these two pawns but the bishop actually
very comfortably defends both of the
pawns and if something like Knight C5
then trades and the blacks pass Pawn can
actually become very dangerous even if
they lose C6 so I think black's position
is already quite comfortable
but A4 denied one to D2 so he took only
two what the idea is is giving up E2 to
take on C6 but once the E2 Pawn is gone
this D4 Pawn is quite lonely and as we
saw in the game in the final position
this Pawn did fall so we will see how so
Bishop goes to B5 Knight takes one C6
now black has um
okay I was thinking blackheads take
immediately but Rook seed is nice
and takes on A4 and this is very
Tactical
with the idea if you take I take my
knight is hanging but so is your Bishop
and again black should have a bit of an
edge playing against an isolated Pawn
but too many traits have happened at
this point
so instead after Queen A4 Bishop took on
C6
Knight V6 and we see how the font the
pawn fell Rook D1 so now the Knight is
threatening to jump to E4 actually I
think this is quite a serious threat
tonight went to D5
and this is the position and actually
this is the last position we saw and
that bd5 was played and this is a mover
we're predicting
yeah so
um
can 94 be played right now or is there
some tactical problem with that move
to
simplification and giving up a pawn so I
cannot go to E5 I think my queen only
has
um
see if I hold the queen I'll tell me all
the legal moves but I think I only have
I can go to
B6 no B6 yeah C6 actually might keep I'm
surprised you don't lose because oh you
have a rook C6 at the end because Rook
D5 you can take on C6 with a piece
I wanted to be clever here and force a
drop but you can just cooking h8 just
wanted to end this game in a draw okay
so 94 I have to go to yeah this looks
um a bit suspicious I don't want to
allow this
right the Knight on D5 is a little
overworked and maybe this like even The
Rook end game might not be so bad
anymore this 4v3 doesn't feel as
dangerous as a normal 4v3 yeah we will
put a rook on F4 I think uh good chances
for white
and um so instead of Queen B6 where are
we okay D1 wait no Knight P85 actually
wasn't played I just realized that this
was our old analysis so I have to keep
remembering that the red square is the
move so if Knight bd5 which I think is a
very logical move maybe the other one is
to move the queen because 94 is actually
like if I pass the move
A4 looks like a serious threat
sure where you go to protect P6 I guess
you have
I guess you have to play Queen C4
it's probably it right
because C4 and C6 are hanging so it must
be Queen C6 and like Rook C6 and maybe
or queen C6 I I don't think black has
very good chances
maybe I can come this way
yeah play against hero compromise King
yeah like King G7 I I don't know I mean
obviously I I think white has good
chances yeah I I don't think we want to
allow this Knight F6 GF yeah so instead
I think that bd5 oops what am I doing
like bd5
yeah instead of it
yeah we passed unfortunately yeah so I
think this is my only move right this is
the only score I can go to with the idea
of Queen system and kicking uh
this away actually 94 is a huge threat
because there will be Fork one C3 so
white will have to
um
probably have to take something right
I don't know if you want to give up this
bishop because all of a sudden your king
looks a bit
vulnerable although I don't see how I
can go after it right the um also I
think when you're down material and
these sorts of defensive positions you
want the opposite piece so like I think
Knight F6 might be a better tribe with
him like Bishop F3 or something or
should you too you're afraid of this
yeah I just wanted to guard the G4
square but maybe it wasn't that
important
a rook C2 is also yeah but there's no
threat so maybe we need to defend the
second rank
get everything yeah
possible but definitely black is for
Choice up a pawn and um if black trades
the Rooks which I think black wants to
do then you can have Queen and Knight
against Queen and Bishop which I think
is a good combination to have
and
another game I will I want to look at is
the game between quesada Perez and
Benjamin Bach and the reason I wanted to
look at is because this um
three pieces versus queen and this is
another Dynamic we see very often so at
first glance well the first thing that
stands out to me is The Rook on A6 which
looks very out of the game but let's see
what is going on in this position and
who is for Choice here what do you think
well unfortunately for me I just see the
evaluation bar so immediately that
brings my attention to or I it gives me
the preference for black but I think
even without the bar I like Black's
position because the Bishops are staring
um at at the um at the center and we're
about to break through and it's not
entirely clear how white is going to
make progress with his queen against
Black's King
so so what was the last move so the last
move the bishop went to so The Rook went
on A6 and to me The Rook on A6 unless he
wants to take on B6 for very concrete
reason Rook on A6 looks um very out of
the game maybe The Rook means to be here
to defend this Pawn
so he played Rook A6 and Bishop C6 and
now he cannot move this pawn and he
cannot move this Pawn because of this
pin
because I would like to play maybe
something like this but I can't to be
honest with you I think that like
White's position is statically bad like
almost if you put White's pieces any in
your hair I mean not literally anywhere
maybe you could figure some way to check
maybe but I I just like the two Bishops
um when you have the three pieces for
for the queen I think the best
combination is two Bishops and a knight
as opposed to two knights in a bishop
yeah two Bishop especially when your
Bishops have Outpost so the bishop on V6
has an outpost and
uh Bishop on can go to B7 where it will
be defended so when we evaluate this
kind of imbalances of Queen versus
anything
Queen vs to Rose queen versus three
pieces the first thing we'll look at is
King safety and if the king is unsafe
that the queen is quite powerful and
here actually Black's King does look
unsafe but it's surrounded by its pieces
so there is no way to get to it and the
fact that white doesn't have a minor
piece so if White had a dark Square
bishop and black had another Knight this
would be a completely different story
but unfortunately white is only playing
with the heavy pieces and another thing
that we have to consider is the quality
of the pieces and then if the pieces can
be unsecured squares because if the
miners constantly get kicked around by
the Rooks then their quality is not as
good but here these are very strong
Bishops yeah I think Keen safety is
definitely the number one concern when
it's queen versus anything I played a
very interesting game against Talia
which I probably should have lost where
she had um she had Queen in four pawns
for a rook in three pieces
which seems like a lot but my cane was
unbelievably weak so it was just dead
lost so she went a piece back in the
Niagara Rook uh I had a rook in two
pieces for a queen and two pawns and I
was suffering the entire game and
somehow managed to draw wait rook and
two pieces is that the one where you had
no that's not your game that was someone
else's game it was I remember this like
amazing Fortress
um it was eventually a fortress but
maybe not my game
I've had queen versus three pieces
against Curry since 2019 us Championship
but my queen was very strong
and it just kind of captured all her
pieces because her pieces just didn't
have any squares but let's see how we
got here so let's go back
so we see a Spanish and we see an
so this looks like a archangels some
kind of a transposition right even
though the pawn is on D3
so Bishop G5 again I never really
cared much about this bishop G5 lines I
don't know what your opinion on this is
but I always thought that the arc angles
when white plays D3 is supposed to be
not as dangerous if The Bishop's on C8
versus uh versus B7 so
um I'm uh what why did white choose this
uh specific move order in your opinion
uh maybe he was avoiding something or he
had a very specific preparation I mean
people don't always want to play open
Spanish there's so many lines to know I
always played with D3 because I just now
learned to open Spanish
uh so maybe he's avoiding something
so I think it's a possibility that's the
downside I guess of playing D3 here
instead of castling yeah the three does
give black a lot of options because if
you're castling then
um
you know you're ready for this take on
C6 lines for this this lines
um kind of um doesn't give like as much
flexibility but T3
does um does make I think maybe life a
bit easier for plug in some sense
so Bishop C5 is played
so A4 drug has to go on B8
and Bishop G5 and I think this is a
critical moment so this position has
been played
several times at the higher level so I
see eventually has played italic save
has played it
so H6 and Knight G5 very thematic
sacrifice
um doesn't work out very often
and the idea for why it is to be able to
play a four or at least put some kind of
pressure so Knight c395 is not possible
yeah I think uh people's opinion of
these sorts of sacrifices change over
time like um when you're pretty low
rated you think oh well I just want a
piece so you shouldn't sacrifice uh uh
sacrifice
um a piece for two pawns and then you
get a little higher rate and you're like
oh well Black's cane is weak I'm
probably just going to Checkmate him you
get hired you're like oh I don't put
peace again and then eventually like ah
I think it's equal it depends how much
you analyze what a computer do
and King G7 queen of three rookie shade
Bishop D5
and before so this is
this is actually kind of funny because
white is just kind of playing down a
piece like it's not a big deal but the
idea is for this Knight to
somehow land on D5 this is longer a
longer term
idea and we actually have couple of
games in this line that have been played
so this whole line at 27 the Knight goes
to
stay tuned so I think already black is
afraid of 93 and for black it's um I'm
starting to think that the big downside
is that bug just doesn't have too many
useful moves and doesn't really have a
way of getting out of this pin because
if you go here I will simply play H4 and
this did not really help you
and the Knight is still headed
um so 93. so let's say okay if I just
pass the move and you go 93 my whole
point is you can never take because this
just helps me
yeah this is just game over
so this idea of 93 this long-term idea
and either I don't think you want to
take 166 probably move back and put a
knight on D5 or actually Knight E3 take
on C6 disrupt this bishop on Knight G4
that looks very strong so a very long
term idea but very hard to deal with so
black already has to sense the danger
which is why he took on D5
so now white has to take because this
runs into a queen G5 25 and there has to
be something very bad here I I don't
know I think you can just play like even
Bishop E6 or something I think that
white White's positions just statically
again like really bad we have two
Bishops and is is black skin really weak
The Rook on B8 is probably going to go
to like G8 or we can double on the H
file I think maybe White's the one
that's getting in trouble with his skin
yeah piece is a piece and I think
two Bishops in this kind of positions
look devastating which is why after
Knight D5 why took
takes back so now this is how we got
queen versus three pieces so D4
Rook H6 so it looks like white is doing
well here The Rook wants to cover the
king
oh wow so I just saw the bar drop Queen
G3 was was that big of a mistake
um so just you know why it's just Rook
into the game so what should white have
done
uh Knight to E3 I don't think it's a
possibility because you just take
uh the question is what do I want to do
with this Center do I want to keep it
like this do I want to push do I want to
take I think I don't want to take I
think this should just only help you
yeah the bishop on B6 will become a
monster anytime the d-pawn moves I think
yeah I think like
um
tactically this actually might become a
problem because once you play Rook h8 I
may not be able to hang on to this Pawn
because H3 might run into sacrifices
yeah because of the bishop on B6 you
might even just get checkmated there
will be no F3 defense Rook H1 will come
with mate
um can we try maybe like Queen E3
without the check right without the
check
um I want to play
F4 but maybe even here F4 because if you
take on H2 I was thinking I could maybe
give away my queen oh you wanted to do
this but
it really hates the way that I play I am
giving up a lot of Pawns because now I
just have two pieces because you have
two pawns right Queen and two pawns for
three pieces and now I just have two
pieces for a rook and I still have two
Bishops I don't know which way I want to
take probably this
this is a huge Target for me
yeah two Bishops usually just destroy a
rook
yeah that's a bishop starts a strong
hero so what do we need to do
so H3 here can you sacrifice
[Music]
and what
oh okay yeah but Knight G6 and
even this is practically very hard to
deal with even if objectively it's equal
not there can I make it
trying to meet me
yeah this looks uh
I don't know what this looks like I'm
not sure about it this position but okay
we didn't have to sacrifice on HD maybe
Knight G6
it's more normal I'm going to place a
knight on F4 and then take on HD yeah
when you did that with white it looked
like a really good idea maybe maybe we
should do that with black
because if you go here I can just kick
you away right because the idea like you
got this Tempo with Queen G5 and I'm
going to prevent it
closest position and ask this night
where it's going so you're forced to go
to d8 which is sort of an
achievement for me well if you go to d8
I can claim two things right that you're
not on d8 is just very bad and your Rook
cannot go to age eight so now maybe I
can go something like
um so something like what I think no
matter what you do as black I'd like to
play F6 followed by Knight F7 because
the Knight on d8 doesn't leave a very
good impression I definitely want to
improve that piece oh that's fair points
you want to go to F6 and I wanted to
I had some kind of an idea but
so you will play Bishop D4 right yeah
you're not gonna give me a push-up
now I'm gonna wonder why I made all
these moves
I'm not on time
yeah so I wanted to do something
like this oh good word here
I'm not sure I'm achieving anything I
think you might just yeah take and play
Rick dude oh
yeah that's a nice idea I mean I just
stumbled into it
maybe after maybe after Rook C7 I have
the move for Knight G5
and then when you move your queen then I
play Rook d8 yeah I just have too many
pieces and
for a queen so maybe we can
yeah somehow it feels practically very
hard to play with white even if
objectively like I see the bar it says
that white has some Advantage maybe even
a winning Advantage but
um
I don't know playing with the pieces
like once the pieces start to coordinate
you have to be very careful with the
queen a few
uh don't have an attack then maybe I
need to come and take this bishop and
so let's say I go Rook here you want to
go says
here you go here here Knight of seven
so I take uh okay so if I play if you're
going like G5 I think I will take you
right
so you have to take I'm not even sure
probably with the Rook just not because
I'm afraid of doubling my pawns but
because I'm afraid of Rook A7 coming and
skewing my entire seventh rank yeah you
have a lot of things there maybe I'm
just skewered anyway
but let's try the
right door because
because Queen goes somewhere yeah you're
just threatening H4 and um Rook D7 uh
maybe this yeah I think we found the
reason why white is doing doing so well
it's Rigby's Rook A6 Rook B6 idea but he
was very nice well I mean I Saw The Rook
on A6 in the game and I figured there
has to be a reason right it's not the
such a strong players because it kind of
looks silly to me so I think I figured
that's the reason maybe you have to take
this bishop because it's it's kind of a
very strange thing right you need to
sacrifice this bishop here
uh sacrifice your Rook for this bishop
Raider which is difficult to do because
you don't already don't have a lot of
pieces to play with in your sacrificing
something else the whole the whole
reason to do it is to just make sure the
black seventh rank is so weak like um
concretely if black is allowed to
consolidate like put the net on C6 on G6
or something I think White's in trouble
but yeah White's probably just on time
this D5 or k6 thing is very nice but I
think T5 is a difficult move to play and
for us it's easy to to think of this
move because well one is not our game
and two we saw what happened in the game
right because in the game
as we see Queen G3 was played and after
this we see this dynamic and how
dangerous it is and the reason he's
playing F4 is because
um
what is coming actually Rook H6 is a
threat followed by Knight G6
uh there's um already a lot of pressure
so F words
bit of an ambitious move so takes n94
and apparently Knight D4 is not a very
good move and I can I think I see why 94
is not a good move because if I look at
this Knights these are called
Superfluous Knights they're both
fighting for the same square so both
Knights want to be on C6 but only one
can be but this trade
which feels like a good trade for white
because you're not on
C2 just kind of looks silly
but at the same time it allows this
other piece coming to the game and it
takes the defense away so if we think
about it if I compare it this position
where 96 actually wasn't played Bishop
C6 was played but if I compare this
position to
uh where are we to
this position or even this position
it wasn't like you didn't trade this
night for this night right you traded
this night for this one right and this
is a favorable trade for black so I so
again during the game making this kind
of decision is very difficult once the
bar drops up and down we can draw our
own conclusions but here I can
understand uh why ctx4 is better because
now black has to figure out where to do
with this Knight and F5 is actually
maybe already a move at five F6 it's a
possibility
if I've passed the move somehow very
difficult to pass a move here actually
yeah okay let me pass it like this I
think this is already a huge threat
right because something like this
oh you're just gonna check maybe I hope
so yeah Queen G5 and queen F6 yeah
F7 is not defended by anything so
there's actually a thread in the
position
so keeping the knights on even though
this night looks very bad is useful for
white but I can completely understand
94.
so takes and F5 F5 is a very nice move
because black is so happy to do this
first of all this Pawn is hanging but
also the Knight on F5 is just sits there
beautifully
yeah actually
um yeah there there might be some tactic
like uh like EF Knight F5 if you go like
Queen D2 then Bishop D4 King H1 Rook H2
I think is uh is Checkmate because the
Knight conveniently controls the G3
Square yeah it's a really thematic
checkmate
um yeah so while Yasser is uh suffering
with the position why don't we go ahead
and take a look at the b b parents
as we said we had two players tied for
first place
and we actually have those uh two
players uh playing each other Akshay
Chandra versus Felix blauberger and
let's take a look at what we have in
that game so actually coming back uh
with a win with uh that two rounds ago
he didn't win against Canter but
yesterday he did win his game
so let's take a look at where we are so
what is your impression in this position
so very brave King yeah my the the first
thing that sort of stands out to me is
the bishop on C3 doesn't have very many
squares
um
but yeah it looks it looks Wild
I'm not sure who I would prefer
knee-jerk reaction probably probably
black because I like the space and I I
think White's pieces are a little
awkward but on the other hand
if white activates his Bishop somehow
the K9 G6 might be
might be a little weak and it's hard to
see how black will activate their pieces
I'm actually wondering if we will see a
repetition
because if okay let me see the last few
moves
Bishop went here Bishop one two D4 King
activates
so the queen can move so now C5 is a
move
so he goes back to attack A5
and queen d8 so D4 is a huge threat so
white has to deal with this so I don't
think you want to do something like this
and then your Bishop gets locked in
so I think Bishop D4 is a logical move
question is if white if black wants to
play B6
the daily of C5
and try to
Force white to give up this bishop
hmm yeah I I wonder if um
can white try the move Rook E1 because
if you play the move C5 that does weaken
your D5 Pawn so yeah if I take this then
what is this opposite color bishop and
game with Queens on the board so
um I don't think I
yeah queen of seven Bishop F5 would be
nice for me so tactically already so
here actually I probably will have to
take on F6
um but yeah I mean weakening and if you
somehow force me to put a Pawn on D4
then all of a sudden I put all my pants
on the dark squares
and my Bishop cannot move but even this
looks very close to equal to me
right um no rookie one is a very logical
move I don't think black wants to
[Music]
want
um
P6 I think he ranked Queen E7 with the
queen d8 with a very concrete thread of
D4 and also defending his Pawn so he
didn't want to play B6 here
the V6 will run into rookie one as well
so he just played Queen d8 to
wait so aksha made a move it looks like
he captured something yeah it looks oh
he took on F6
unprovoked I wonder why okay that that
seems like a strange decision to me
because I I kind of like Black's
activity here without the pawn being on
C5 the D5 Pawn doesn't feel that weak
and
um I mean the king can be weak on G6 of
course but it can it can also be active
next I will want to play rookie one and
going through this opposite color Bishop
position
so maybe he didn't like his position
already I wonder why he rejected Bishop
D4
because I don't think in this position
that we have let me promote this so I
don't get lost here that uh I think
black is the one for Choice here because
kingbon G6 is actually like this whole
formation is actually quite favorable
for Vlog I think I can
start attacking here
just pushing this pawns can be pretty
annoying like if I go H5 H4 G4 F4
yeah it's definitely pretty annoying
definitely white the one who who has to
prove something here then I can put a
rook on e4 you have to go C3
this uh so it's not like my A5 Pawn was
going to become a problem so Bishop F6
is a bit committal I think Bishop D4
threatening quote unquote rookie one
like if I'm going to take on F6 at least
I want to have my Rook on E1 already I
think this would have made more sense
and as I mentioned this is also a
possible repetition here right
I was even thinking maybe black one
could play for a win in this position
but it seems unlikely because no matter
what your plane Rook q1 right
yes yeah
because
you have a rook on the open files it's
like very basic chips right there's one
open file on the board only one pair of
puns have come off and black is black
has a rook on that open file and it's
unchallenged so very basic chess
principle tells us that we need to
challenge The Rook on an open file
because our own Rook is not doing
anything
yeah yeah so um
well they are figuring this end game out
do you want to take a look at the other
games in the section sure let's take a
look at um let's take a look at gergel's
game so oh wow
how did this King get here so we're
already on move 42 but so a lot of moves
have been played in this game so girgili
Contour versus Jason Liang
so Jason Liang also won his game
yesterday he had that um
opposite color Bishop end game we were
looking at with that plus C pawn and
eventually he went on to win that
and now this position looks amazing for
black that's my first
reaction I haven't even counted pawns
the screen only for is just such a
monster this bishop on D2 very classical
right yeah octopus on D5
yeah you've been yeah I call any good
night an octopus because you know not a
knight anymore it controls all the
important squares
unfortunately this is
Bishop past pants this Pawn is won't go
far so this Pawn is already hanging can
I already take this guy
ever get made
it something
to worry about so for you to meet me you
have to play here reroute this bishop
yeah reroute some Rooks I also don't
even want to do that just because the
pawn on D4 feels so useless like the uh
the pawn does kind of prevent your works
from coming in in the future so yeah I'm
thinking maybe B3 something to that
effect
um with the idea of like King D3 King C2
even in the future
maybe we can start with King did we okay
how do you defend this King D3 feels
like a really nice move
um you should be one looks very sad
ah but here it might actually threaten
King F3 and like if I go here I think I
might get
how do you stop mate
it's no it's not made
that's how
I prevented it no but if you push your
Pawn
is this
yeah yeah that would be a very
unfortunate way to lose for for black
like a self-made yeah Keen activity can
can turn into
um being in danger very fast I just
realized the king just
three five
I kind of figure the king came from here
but not realizing that yeah there's no
possible way for the king come from this
side so this makes more sense
so he went here
check attacked the bishop the bishop
went back he went here and he just
repeated it and Rook C6 played so he
stops its spawn
so how is black eventually going to win
this so actually what is the pawn count
one two three four five six one two
three four five six so pound count is
equal but this Pawn is ours right
there's no way to ever defend this one
yeah so it's this one actually so you
can choose
but maybe both but doesn't feel like
this is going to be the decisive
um Advantage for a black it feels like
it should be this pond okay I need to
find a move in this position so let's
say if I go here
okay maybe maybe no yeah now that C5 is
hanging taking D4 and now I don't
I don't literally collect it once
okay I need to find a move with white
and I think this is the difficult task
for me
maybe I need to this is very unfortunate
this runs into King D3
he played Rook D1 in the game okay I
guess his idea is that he he didn't want
black to take on D4 yet but should be
four check would be a discovery
okay
so what does so maybe white that's a
black can actually maybe sucks Monk
or do I have kinky too so let's say I
pass the move
well I have to be careful so I don't
have to I was thinking maybe black would
try Knight E7
are you going to F5 all right you want
to take this one
no immediately that move oh oh I pumped
like yeah this is uh uh I spotted this
when I wanted to wait I wanted to go
Rook A7 and then I thought before it's
hanging and I was like no the Knight is
there so the Knight cannot move so what
do we want to do so let me promote this
so how do we win this with white
what do we do
um
we can with black how do we win this
with black yeah actually this I just
realized that this um Discovery is very
uh very loose like King King D3 Bishop
B4 King C2 you have to play uh uh King
D3 Bishop before King C2 you have to
play Rook in D2 I believe not to lose a
piece and then yeah
like everything is
somehow defended
wait maybe I can go Rook C A6 and
everything is trapped
so I have to trade
we don't see a bishop get trapped very
often it's not easy to trap
a pointy yeah
well yeah this is a very unusual pattern
I don't think I've ever seen that before
I went back and then I lost where I came
from okay we're looking at King D3
so maybe not King D4 but King D3 is an
interesting way to try to play for a win
and if I change the move order and I go
here here okay
yeah this this isn't as good
[Music]
okay too but I no I don't have it if
anything you're you're probably in
danger now it's very annoying movement
then this runs into
three
it's a very unfortunate way to lose the
game for a second I thought about
something very silly I was like I
thought Knight C3 check at the end four
came the Kanan Rook which is true but it
was my own King this is where oh very
nice
okay so let's go back to our position
after Rook D1 and
um so let's say we pass the move and
maybe we need to pass the move in a
maybe I need to play here so my Rooks
are defended
so we're not pondering Bishop B4 and
let's say y goes here
actually I don't like this one because
now I cannot push my pan I cannot put a
rook behind it what if what if I go this
way so you make a move and I push
this is is this hanging I don't think
this is hanging safety
take
yeah just for K8 right and then you have
to go back and I can rotate it too yeah
C3 if you go back this is this over
yeah this is just Rook A1
and I don't see you move here because
Knight C3 is a threat and V2 with Rook
A1 is a threat
I think this was just game over
yeah
and Knight F4 is also a threat in
addition to all of those things yeah
yeah see see it's nice when you can move
a few moves in a row until you find a
good move that so you're like ah that
makes sense
yeah this is actually quite a flexible
moment what I like about it that it
connects the Rooks for the Rooks to find
each other which makes makes my night
very flexible and my idea is to start
pushing this pawn and from here I can
put the Rook behind it so I need the
assistance of my Rook to promote this
Pawn
so I actually really like this move and
because on C6 so actually this is a very
nice manure for black it just goes Rook
C6 I guess you could have done it Rook
C8 okay but I like this because he stops
the pawn The Rook moves away and now he
goes back so now someone can go on B8
uh this Pawn doesn't
cannot move because my Rook is here and
also in general I don't think it can
move it too much because
it will just get captured so it seems
Jason is playing very accurately in this
position and uh Cantor just a disastrous
last two rounds for him he had a a very
nice save against against oxshot but his
last two rounds were not um uh not very
easy for him um why don't we go ahead
and take a look at what the players are
playing for
so
um in the a group first place is six
thousand dollars second is four thousand
and third is three thousand with a total
price one of twenty two thousand dollars
they are playing for quite a bit of
money
and in the B group uh first place is
four thousand dollars twenty five
hundred two thousand with a total price
fund of 1400 uh fourteen thousand
dollars uh which is uh definitely no
small uh no Small Change
and as you were telling us what the
players are playing for I went back to
group a to this game between uh quesada
and Benjamin Park and we see things have
changed and now black has still three
pieces for the queen but now it's a real
gun two pieces so
um it's um I'm on the bus about to say
monetary but uh piecewise this is a big
better Point wise better Advantage for
black because Rook is worth more than
the miners but at least we see this B6
Bishop has come off the board so let's
see how we got here
so we left off somewhere around here so
this happened at five this is something
we saw so The Rook went down A6 and
eventually of course
sacrifice itself
Rook G3 so this was whole idea behind
Rook F3 to get rid of one of these
attackers
to fend off this attack somehow 95 very
annoying move
Queen goes to D2 and simply wants to
start collecting everything and
eventually
uh yesterday
decides that just cannot deal with all
these pieces I mean yet this King and
gets rid of one of them
and now at least he gets some kind of
counter play via C6 I've I've just
received news that apparently Savion is
uh there's a lot of action going on in
the savian game
we will go right there once we see the
final position and queen takes on B6
next the queen will take this
and still should be an advantage for
black but
um
but actually if the Rook goes to situ
this actually might be entering
Checkmate territories so we'll come back
to this game but let's take a look at
that game
oh wow what is going on here
so Queen F6 would be made but there is a
rook on B6 how did how did this happen
this is such a funny Constructor
ha
and D4 well supported yeah this is like
an ideal center right you have two ponds
in the center and then you have to upon
supporting it so what is the material
one two three four it's probably a
groonfeld right that's what I would
guess I
I have no idea of course
so for nights oh I have seen this line
before and at some point F3 is played
because you don't want to place this
this really weakens the structure so
instead F4 after it gets played we need
to take this Pawn
and okay we'll see how we got this part
so King goes to defend the pawn
and kingy two it's a very very funny
game by white so far it's King County
this is a really interesting right this
is everything we'll learn not to do King
on the in the center on an open file but
there's just no way to get to it and
rookie one which is a very clever way of
Defending because if you take
takes takes and can give one there's no
defense
backwards King wolf right it's so funny
because we talk about backwards moves in
chess and how difficult they are to spot
backwards Knight moves but backwards
king move it's not a tactical
sequence we're familiar with so the
Knight went back the King goes to safety
okay so now we're going to see
and we got this Pawn structure oh this
position looks very dangerous for black
because it's white I have a compromise
Kink but there's just no way to get my
Kink because white just has such a
lock on the center and
the queen can go to G2 to stop any kind
of queen H3 checks and the center is
great to Bishops
open file and I also have to mention
that the end games are also really bad
for black because of the two Bishop
sources tonight yeah I think the end
games might be even worse than the
current position I think if you traded
Queens here black would be
um without very much hope of any sort of
counter play whereas here he can sort of
dream that one day he can generate an
attack against the white cane
um also uh yeah uh white white moved is
Keen around a lot in the opening but one
of the opening principles is to control
the center and white has done a great
job of following that principle
so we'll go through it too and now we
see and attack is coming and it's funny
because he's also not developing this
bishop but the bishop doesn't really
have a square it can go to where I can
claim that it's better than on C1
so now the Knight goes back and I see a
very lonely King here with no Defenders
and white just goes for the attack
Bishop 86 very good way to develop the
skin immediate this bishop immediately
attacking D7 so G6 is forced but without
dark squared Bishops there's um without
black star Square Bishop this is
very weak as we sign the final position
so black is trying to create some kind
of counter play
and H4 H5 very typical against the
structure
so if white manages to do this and take
on G6 will be devastating or given very
logical move
so we're Trading
the bishop goes to E2 so he brings the
defender but now another attacker is
coming and the problem is for black is
both of your defensive pieces are
completely on the other side of the
board and unfortunately they're Knights
which means they're not coming back
anytime soon it's very difficult for
Knights to move from one side of the
board to the other just takes too many
moves and sometimes they just get
trapped lights are very awkward pieces
as Sam learned yesterday so again his um
in a different kind of position but he
has a knight versus Bishop where his
Knights are getting dominated yesterday
it was an end game today is a middle
game
yeah the issue for for black is you're
not even up anything like white has this
very shown attack and
um it's not clear what your competence
like we think of compensation as for
like material but
um there's not a lot of compensation for
White's attack here like what is black
really doing on the queen side right now
okay usually when you're suffering this
much at least at least you have a pond
red you're like okay yeah
yeah here it just uh suffering
so in the game Roxy one was played
doesn't wanna give up a pawn
so if I take this way you have to take
this way right because this is just yeah
this is meat yeah yeah so you have to
take this way which also gives white
this past Pawn
I mean the position is very bad but H6
G6 is quite committal there is no reason
to do that maybe we can start with um
so if I go here and you take do I have
made
well I guess I suppose I can do this
but I also don't know if I want my
Bishop on this
can we change the order of that can we
go D5 first and then Bishop F6
like if your workouts are like somewhere
that's not the sixth it probably used to
be six then I was Bishop F6 becomes a
lot stronger
yeah now we have ideas of moving this
bishop back and
yeah and also I was yeah I mean that
looks that looks really good
yeah that's nice
won't be captured and then I don't
but not can start coming back but not uh
it won't be going too far
but let's see what happened in the game
Rook C1 was played right they're making
moves
rugby six Bishop H6 and Knight B2 and
ice wait some trades happened
he took on H5
wow no wait this position is way
different than what's on the screen
where's the queen
is a good question
yeah so where is Black's Rogue so I see
a rook out of six and Bishop on H6
forming a mating net against blacks came
but ah there's a rook on F6 uh so
they're going to some kind of a king and
pawn end game so I say 995 so we're not
getting updates
so let me go to another game and come
back and see if we get updates now this
is the position so disappointing that
the dgt might be having an error right
now so let's think about how we could
have gotten to this position so this
somehow got traded
so somehow he sacrificed the queen
blackheaded upon an H4 somehow
so he took on H5 and then pushed H4 but
white has a pawn in H5 also
updating but
um
the bar is telling us the position is
completely winning hopefully we get the
most soon
maybe if we get a close shot of the
board we can kind of figure out what's
going on
um so he played so we're gonna get some
kind of a I think white still has a
bishop so we're about to get some kind
of a
visual versus knight and game so I'm
actually really curious how the spawn
landed on H4 did he go G5 at some point
did he catch or something Sam must have
found some some resource to get out of
that Massive Attack
I would imagine he took on H5 and put a
rook on G6 somehow and the queen was
sacrifice but I don't know how white
still has a Pawn on H5
so
um if assuming there's a bishop on E2
which I kind of assume is the case
otherwise
um I think white would be a lot less
happy with this position
um maybe the queen just dominated and we
can try to win
uh slowly with like Bishop D3 F5 E6
so I'm trying to figure out so there's a
Pawn on E5 so I want D5 so then that
goes to C4
and
so what happened
yeah I think I can make out most of the
position I think the structure is the
same but you want that for okay right
this is the only thing that
that makes sense
yeah somehow we traded Our Queen for
Black's night on C4 and Rook on F6
and uh we play we got our Rook to F6
while taking away the f and g pawns
while the the G Pawn became an H Pawn
um and yeah I mean this position also
looks pretty lost for black I think
problem is in the position we have white
doesn't have to play Rook f8 immediately
he pushes the pawn ah maybe he's
actually sacrificed the bishop and his
pawns are queening wait
Buck also has a postpone what is going
on
the pawn is on C5 somehow okay
yeah maybe yeah there's no way I can
figure so much out yeah
um it's kind of fun it's uh what is it
called like regressive chest when you
have a position you have to figure out
how you get there yeah yeah so let's
take a look at what we have in the other
game so this position we don't have any
updates this game which is Casada Perez
and Benjamin bug and Christopher you
versus daro so now we have an end game
of rook and Knight versus Rook Bishop
for versus three and
eventually it's a real good Paul to go
here and offer an exchange but uh black
I think you can try to press this for a
long time I think this gives white some
good chances yeah that's actually
interesting would you play the move
rookie 2 and allow a rook trade because
I would be unsure about this decision
I mean I would be unsure too but if I
would play it that's it that's a
different question oh actually when
reach move 40 so I think this is going
to be a long thing
uh so you think having rook's favorite
is white I'm I'm not sure because on the
one hand
um no because the Rook on the second is
very annoying and targets F2 but on the
other hand if I if I trade my Bishop for
your knight now I'm probably just losing
whereas in the previous position if I
trade my Bishop for your night I'm I'm
ecstatic
that makes sense uh is there threat in
this position is 94 is not a move so
white has to find a move because I think
if I move my Rook at five now Knight G4
is a threat yeah and now actually you
cannot challenge me here right now you
don't have Rook before anymore so you
have to defend something like this and
this looks a bit awkward already
this looks like a bit of a concession so
I don't necessarily have to play rookie
2 but I do have to like make a move like
maybe bishop E2 with the idea of going
Rook E3 or something to that effect
by let's say pass you go you just wait I
just want to wait
let's see
but then you can move your Bishop if I'm
not threatening then upon right yeah
like the the square I care the most
about is Knight G4 I think the other
scores I'm more than happy to let you be
on
see how we got here where did we left
off a long time ago right we left off
somewhere around so we saw all of this
we saw this was on 95 this was and queen
before Oh for some reason without Queen
E7 is the only move we've missed Queen
before and a line which takes F6 and I
think the reason we're wanting to go
Queen A7 is Knight F6 can be met with
Knight F6 we didn't want this Pawn
structure change
and after Queen before the Knight is
overworked so the Knight cannot take
Pawn has to take Queen goes to A6 avoids
a trade but
can I go on night before here
you Defenders
where does the queen go to defend
um
oh you go Queen A3 I think because if
Rook C6 I have Rook C6 and then I can't
take because of the pin so a queen must
take and then Queen B4
and I've saved myself
and I have to say bite is quite happy
about this exchange because without the
miners
they have more more of a chance of
trying this and especially against the
sweet King I can always check Queen F4
creates some threats and I think this
will end in a draw
yeah instead here instead of night
before Rook C7 is played and eventually
we entered
um
so takes it's also possible to keep the
Queens on here but
yeah it went for the end game route the
eight yeah I'm surprised the black
traded traded Queens because I would
think that your winning chances go up if
Queens are on the board for black as
opposed to off the board like maybe
Queen E7 just be
be solid somehow play F5 next why do you
think
the Queens
maybe Queen E7 is a bad move but the the
reason why I think that is
um what I'd really like to do is trade
the Rooks and then play Queen and Knight
against
Queen and Bishop or maybe your Kane
becomes a little weaker
but he decided to decide to go for the
end game maybe he thought he has good
chances in the end game so H4 with the
threat of H5 King slide steps the Knight
will eventually land here with the
thread of Knight F3 so King covers
book the two
so repeat once and we trade and that's
how we got here and I think few tomorrow
moves were played
so before was played
G4 oh G4 is a brave move why is this
move necessary
seems like you're just weakening and
H5 but it just looks like you're giving
your opponent
um
just uh squares but I think is does he
think he has a fortress here because
does he want to put his King on G3 maybe
he doesn't want a long Knight to G6 oh
but why H6
oh maybe okay G5 possibly is a thread
here but why not here
all right so actually if you play that
um oh it's funny uh if the Rook being on
e4 is actually really bad because well
if you play G5 here with white then FG
loses a piece but King G5 F4 seems like
it oh it's also illegal I was thinking
F4 or King F5 but uh yeah this tactic
just never works well that's why I
wanted to go here so you don't have King
G5 I have F4
but uh so I think I think maybe he
thinks he has a fortress because the
Knight cannot go here but um and then I
can put a king on G3
but uh feels kind of unnecessary to put
all your pawns on the light squares
yeah it seems like you're asking for
trouble with the bishop
[Music]
from your own King
on the other hand if we manage to trade
our f-pawn for for White's g-pawn in a
clean way I think that H5 could end up
being very weak so if you just took
these pants off the board right yeah so
you need maybe put your knight on E7 or
something and then push up five
yeah I'd be thinking about something
like that so then in that case white
would need to put a bishop on D3 and
always be aiming at that pawn
so okay so I think black will play this
for a long time
because black has nothing to lose you
have a knight you can hop around with a
knight in this kind of position you're
actually quite happy to have a night
this Knight can go to all kinds of
squares like G5
so I think we're in for a long game here
and some games we haven't looked at like
Mishra versus nishnik
okay this position looks like
completely drawn end game I want to say
just not enough pounds on the position
yeah I put here and then just go back
and forth I don't can you attack this
slow but even if you capture this I
don't think you can win because it's on
the same diagonal yes the one diagonal
rule right yeah
so this game will end in a draw and we
have collectura versus tarda this is
probably already ended in a draw right
is this a well we're Richmond about 41
so
so if I go Queen E3
this loses right because you're in the
Square that's not the square that's the
square
uh so write this down a pond but this
postpon is running
and how do we stop this Pawn
no Queenie tables
um I also know this this theoretical
endgame which um nobody believes me when
I say it if white trades F pawns here
uh and you don't have an a pawn and your
King's in the corner a lot of ifs but
that position where blackhead is up two
fawns is a draw yeah I've seen this I
think it was Fabiano versus Maxime they
were playing in some tournament and I
think Fabiano had two pawns and he
couldn't win somehow eventually he like
stumbled into it I think this was all
drop it didn't believe it was that in
the sink Field Club I think that Central
cop I think I saw that in the sinkfield
cup it could be mistaken but I know oh
yeah it wasn't a single cop it was that
night or right and then eventually ended
up with these two ponds and the King was
in front eventually he found the win but
it's so tricky because there's just so
many checks it's so difficult to
calculate I think you have to know some
of these positions right the queen and
games are really tough for human players
to play correctly
check in this game see if we have more
oh okay
okay all right so now let's see where
this came from so we left somewhere
around
south of this
so we said this this is the final
position with us so let's see how we'll
end it there
so Rook takes Bishop B2
so the other rule goes on the sixth rank
wait
this for some reason I hallucinated for
a sec okay the night goes SEC back tries
to take it that's not no actually we did
this right so the Knight goes back
now he pins and he probably six okay
ah this is how this happened and then
Rook B6 takes Rick F6 okay very nice
oh this is how we got this this is there
is no way we could have guessed this
right so he goes 28 and then he says
Rook Cafe probably win but I don't have
to you don't have moves and D5 is very
nice complete domination against uh the
queen so you should have played that
forces for somehow so you can have the
same structure but one uh
that would be quite an opposing Center
it's already overwhelming I didn't go
for it he just needs to take this Pawn
bring his future back and go C4
and Bishop G it this is game over
he will just be up a piece but it's two
in a row for some he was leading the
tournament at some point or call leading
because he did have that really nice win
that Rogan game versus Darda but now
he's losing two in a row and more 40
Maybe
maybe this game is already over a really
nice Domination by white yeah such a
beautiful position unfortunate for Sam
losing two games to uh domination ideas
it goes to show you should you should
study your end games and these sorts of
patterns and not let your opponent have
all the Bishops
but this position
was a quite dangerous right yeah
I mean in some ways maybe you can create
some kind of a blockade but again this
potential of the bishop
Bishop four and why did manage all of
these things actually was quite
dangerous so I'm gonna pretend the
teachings that we that we talk about to
beginners actually isn't isn't so bad so
the first principle we teach people is
control the center and even though
White's cane has moved a lot
um he is definitely controlling the
center and has the bishop pair so that's
why it's okay to play This Way in this
circumstance and it's not this specific
circumstance
so tomorrow we're going to have a game
where one side has a center but they're
getting made and be like wow you can't
get the center but don't get meaty right
yeah I have this with my students
sometimes and
they'll be like
um but you know you taught me this or
like I'm supposed to be doing this I'm
like okay the chess is complicated you
know it's not like you learn one rule
and then you always play yeah
um I've I've just learned that Sam
resigned in that game and we will be
getting an interview with uh with
Nordica okay
and let us take a look at Group B in
this akshat versus Felix game
and wow A lot has happened in this game
so it has been a complete change of the
structure so where we left off was
somewhere around here so white plays D4
and black continues with Queen E6 and
after 26 simply controlling the only
open file and this is why we didn't want
to trade our Bishop because we said that
the Rook needs to go T1
and after Bishop F1 H F4
and
we see some more structural changes and
the problem for white is going to be
this king is actually coming under
attack
so D5 has happened this trade and this
bishop actually came to life which is
something white was trying to avoid with
this move d4 this looks quite dangerous
already G4 and H4 so because of the pin
this G3 Pawn is hanging
so white decides to take and now G3 so
black is going to end up with a pass pan
on F2 but at the same time he also
compromised his King
so maybe Queen F4 was a bit more
accurate with the thread of G3 and not
leaving uh white with this extra Pawn
but G3 is played move 40 so I would
expect aksha to go into a long thing and
figure out what to do so of course he
has to take probably King G2 and
and play this position
and
perhaps something like this try to
exchange coins and we do have a guest
with us we have the winner of group a
order by Jacob congratulations on your
win was a beautiful game great
domination uh please take us to the game
I prepared this line
English fortnite so it's E3 and
Queen City yeah we should be for Quincy
too take take
and I expected that
he'll play this sixth year
thanks
he had one game against so
yeah 2018.
um
okay
but he went E4 Knight G5
Queen E7 here is D5 also but uh
and
Group after rugby once
[Music]
what say it's just a big big line
yeah H6 is not best because CD and Rook
B5 oh okay so this was the whole point
[Music]
yeah it's just uh this big line he went
to Queen E7 which is the main line
at three
D5 uh take it take and Castle D4 uh I
think D4 is not here
okay I
I prefer this trap
it
D5 D5 looks very logical but it's uh
not not best so this is your trap yeah
after King F2 why it's better here
because of your country
I think he missed the
I think he missed to move King F2
what else what else if not rookie one
yeah
because uh what if before E4 then Bishop
F5 right
now I cannot do the same thing because
now you
know yeah so this was your trap he went
rookie one and is it possible to take
take and key F1 yeah
uh he had to play Bishop G4 after King
F2
okay yeah
24 E4 take on F3 gf3 and queen H4 check
King G2 Knight F4
take take and queen C1 and next Queen E3
it's just White's better
engine says that
0.50 yeah it's about like that
okay
but this is this end game you would say
it's very bad right because from close
C5 this bishop is very strong yeah white
is still better yeah so after King F2 he
won Knight F6 which but which before was
uh the correct yeah main line after
United F6 uh
I I don't know how much I am why it's
better but
um this is not a very I don't know how
strong this engine is actually but
you're giving you significant advantage
and especially after this
the
just simply yeah Knight E4 was
the best I think
because uh
after Bishop G4
okay
Bishop G4 E4
uh take take here she got he got
uh worst uh version of in
defense
uh construction is so nice so did you
think you're already close to winning in
this position
close to winning yeah
what do you want what I want uh if he
plays Knight E4 then
Bishop B3
take take
H6 King G1 and next
yeah Bishop D3 E4 Rook F1 uh
looks uh
is that your moves all look very easy to
play right like every piece has a square
that your plan is very easy and it's not
clear where black will find counter play
and he doesn't even have a that's what
we were talking about he didn't even
have a pawn for this attack it's just
everything is just clean for you
and then you went Bishop G4
the bishop F3 nice five
here I uh I was trying to
I was trying not to uh
Miss some tactical resource
but okay I
95 from E2 Knight B6 Rook G2 Rook Rook
is uh
various active placed here
yeah and it's nice or so far away from
this parking
D7
I think
five and you're playing very safe here
right you don't not at some point he
attacked your pawn and then you decided
when he came to attack your Pawn
I didn't want to give any chances right
yeah Rook C1
rugby six
and then he went back yeah uh
Bishop B5 is coming here
oh that sounds nice if I can see I want
to pass the moment I can so for example
if he goes here just Bishop B5 and if
you take
she
she'll be five no I was trying to show
what do you mean
I went here oh you didn't okay here you
want to repeat one yeah now uh Brooke
Rook takes B2 is kind yeah this was very
nice so you took because we saw this on
the but we didn't have the most sides
another shot but we couldn't figure out
like how did this Pawn get to H4 and
we're trying to think of ways this was
possible for this one to take the queen
we just couldn't figure out but this is
so beautiful because your Rook just goes
such a nice sequence
and you decided you don't need to rush
because after Vision H6 I have a
I'm not sure that I
I'm winning yeah this domination is just
so beautiful and then now your Bishop
comes too and now you just um you should
be six for Cafe that list and you're
winning yeah very nice game such a
beautiful domination so congratulations
again and good luck to you in the rest
of your games thank you very much and
that was nodded back yakubayov uh who
just won his game against Samuel Savion
who suffered his second last in a rough
and we can continue looking at where we
are
so we might be getting another result
soon as in this game versus quesada
Perez and Benjamin Bach a lot of moves
have happened and now we see that black
is up a piece
so let's see how we landed here we had a
lot of uh
trades and ex change of positions here
and imbalances I'm going back too far
so we were here
H3 Knight one two F6 so take some B6
this is the final position we saw The
Rook on C8 Pawn to G4
and simply giving up a pun and
King H5 I was actually thinking simply
Knight F6 to block the check and this
this is a very nice configuration that
doesn't allow any checks but the idea
behind King H5 is very simple Rook C1 is
check and when we're checkmating
actually with the Bishop on the Knight
this is a way to kind of keep the king
in
so Rook siban is a huge threat and King
runs away but unfortunately can cannot
go too far and the queen doesn't have
any checks so the King on H5
surprisingly is very safe and this king
is getting mated
so I think this G4 move is very
dangerous
so Bishop F3 is still trying to
checkmate
King is running and Rook C2 so Rook C2
is threatening the queen
not like that but like this
and again the queen doesn't have any
checks
and if I can pass the move somehow just
to show what's happening so rookie 2 is
the threat if the king moves then rookie
6 is made and if
King F1 then King G1
this is actually a really nice made Rook
G3 and Knight F1
and all three pieces working together to
Checkmate the king yeah I didn't see
that I was gonna take White's Queen but
I was also since I was checking
eventually I was like oh wait that's a
checkmate so in the game after rookie
took queen127 to sacrifice herself and
now Knight F6
excuse me
so if it's possible for this King to
somehow take this pawn it will be a drop
but unfortunately that's not possible
so if Knight D5 in this position
so this might actually not be accurate
so here here and
the king comes here so what I don't like
about this Knight D5 check is because
this Knight on the pawn I think a really
good job of keeping this King out
because I cannot come this way to this
pawn and I cannot come out come this way
so 95
um
and allows the king to get closer and
now play this move with the idea of
going after this Pawn so let's try to
make some moves so let's say I'm working
D4 so now this is a huge thread so you
have to play here
and is this a drum
ah you know how this might be a draw for
example if you go King F6 let's say King
D5
now
I have to draw like this
and if you go here and this is a mutual
ink because you cannot move your knight
ever I will take your pawn and your king
can never capture my Pawns
and uh yeah both sides are sort of stuck
so again we found the most forcing moves
to force to drop but this is not
necessary so I don't think Knight D5
should be played so maybe King G4 or
King G6 I don't know which one is
correct so let's try one
uh kimchi 4 was played in the game I
believe okay so let's try this one I
don't think I don't think it's a
difference because if here this should
be a very simple win
actually King G4 just makes so much
sense for attacking a pawn
yeah here at Knight C7 when you go take
the Knight we just take your B Pawn
we're in we're in time
India obviously white skin needs to be
on B2 in this position to make a draw
and you can't even draw an arrow to get
there
so King G4 was played uh so D5 is not a
move it's uh we determined and if King
D3 then
this is just even easier if you go here
I don't even have to take I can just go
King E5
yeah a lot lots of very technical end
games for the last two rounds
um I've gotten word of two results so
glad duden has won his game in the B
group and so has michalevski
oh mikovsky has won a lot of he has a
lot of decisive results
so he won three games he lost yesterday
right and he won three games I believe
very very funny player actually it's
unclear what happened in the dude game
apparently maybe the ggt glitched well
97 what a nice move
everything is hanging so the idea is if
you take
we are up a lot apart it's just the
entire King site yeah this is too many
ponds very nice game and in
so we're setting up for the interview we
left off here whoa a lot of things
happen here so the position
I was considering Queen F4 Instead This
was played takes takes King Jutsu and GF
and now
uh I don't know a bit scared maybe if I
move a rook on G3 maybe if I go through
G5 although I am scared of rookie one
I don't know if I should be for example
if I go here the question is whose skin
is weaker because it's opposite color
Bishops
so whose King will come under attack I'm
assuming
just can I move my Kink yeah that's what
I was wondering as well wait
so if I play King H6
like Rook G5 can I go Rook G7
oh King H6 is kind of
annoying the face so here
my intention is is not subtle I just
want to take G5 and play Queen G1 and if
I play this this is
um
cannot be good because
okay here I'm just letting you get a
queen this was unfortunate so after Rook
G7 I cannot take
so maybe I shouldn't go Rook till five
but what can I do here
I'm wondering can I go
uh this is kind of sad but okay if you
play this
yeah
I cannot like I put a king on F1 on my
Bishop list yeah it's impossible to lose
yeah
okay so I will not lose this
um instead of so after Queen D2 maybe I
should try
um
play some other move although I don't
like My Little Queen it is a bit of a
sad move because I'm just like please
please make a drop Queen C6 might be
annoying
on Bishop D5 you have
the things
um and then maybe queen I'm playing with
with a lot of fire trying to win but I'm
just trying to draw yeah yeah Queen D5
yeah
that sort of puts the kavosh on a lot of
my ideas
um
so
yeah but maybe actually even cage
but maybe here you just go here and
yeah
yeah bit of a tough spot so this is not
what we're expecting in this game
without what kind of um
get a lot of Trades that can be some
kind of end game but we also said in
that position that blocks moves are very
easy just push all these Pawns
another game we're looking at this was
this Jason Leon game so let's see if
black managed to make some progress
actually I don't think many moves were
played
so we left off here right we're going to
see it can get to Rook V8 getting ready
to push the pawn Rook C1
he grabbed the Pawn King F3
a bit of an achievement actually
Bishop B1 and now G5 oh wow
yeah so Black's Point must be if F takes
G5 he wants Keane E5 and then he will
try to
collect more more of white spawns and
White's point with Bishop to E1 is you
can't actually take the C5 Pawn because
white will play the move Bishop F2 and
collect your Rook
would be an unfortunate series of events
but I think
here is threat for if I pass the move
when you go rogate two how do I stop
this mate
I don't think you have a way
I'm so excited here yeah that's the
surprise but then you collect this Pawn
too
yeah actually maybe
yeah maybe white still has chances there
because after Rook 8 Rook A2
um Knight C3 Rook D2 if you take C5 I
can play Rook C2 back and try to capture
your try to capture your knight and if
you go to D4 I'll check you and go back
35 now you don't even have this because
no I just collect failure that's fonts
on the dark squares
and whitetook which makes a lot of sense
and now black but uh
this kind of feels like white is getting
some kind of play no unless the spawn is
just going to Queen very soon yeah
Cantor puts up a lot of resistance when
he's in trouble uh the day before yes
yesterday he obviously saved a very bad
position and even yesterday
uh he lost but he did he did put up a
fight longer than uh than we thought he
was going to
it's never easy with him he's very
resourceful player but uh I'm actually
I'm wondering if
she will turn on our evil arrival is not
impressed at all because no oh the
problem is that the bishop moves the
knights come in but um
who did this excuse me who did this Palm
trade's favorite feels like
feels like this Pond should have fell
for free right this F4 Pawn so maybe
there's some chances of counter play for
um white here yeah I think even though
objectively black is still losing that
the
um the trend is in White's favor I think
that
um black was a lot happier one or two
moves ago as opposed to the current
position
yeah
but other games do we have here this
game
uh oh Kirk saved like Kirk was lost
before right so he saved himself yeah
when before the show right was at this
position exactly this looks quite bad
with the two Bishops
so Knight D4 Rook D4 this is what we
were analyzing E3
Rook D1 only move Bishop G4
and he went into some kind of an
opposite color Bishop position and his
opponent took immediately so maybe there
is
no rush to take or there's a rush to
take because this bishop is hanging so
let's say check
and kind of have to right because the
special doesn't I mean I don't think it
makes a difference of doing it this way
yeah I don't know can we try okay I'm
gonna maybe every every move I'm about
to play as a mistake but can I try to
play something like Bishop to D1 here
and then if you take on C4 my idea was
to play oh you're even threatening
Bishop G6 never mind my idea was not
good oh yeah Bishop what was your idea
my idea was to play like H5 and just try
to play with with domination but Bishop
G6 and yeah no I'm getting checkmated
that's unfortunate so maybe this will so
this was a very resourceful uh idea by
Kurt giving up this Exchange
and
now maybe kids to hang on to respawn uh
because
the reason I want to hang out to this
Pawn is because if I eventually wouldn't
be too then this will be a very strong
Class Pawn but I I think this is not an
easy position to play because a lot of
resources for white
at some point if I go E6 this King will
become very loose
so he took Bishop B4 96 is coming and E6
is actually a very serious threat
and queen D3 why not E6
because the six we're not threatening
anything I guess in a sense that it's
not made or anything maybe
B5 is strong here because I have Queen
E2 no can I
yeah you can probably just take
yeah I was hoping Queen E2 would be some
sort of cleverness I have to go here
right everything else mate well yeah but
giving Perpetual was not my dream
forcing a
Church nice uh down a pond with opposite
color Bishops
yeah probably yeah Kirk is not going to
lose this game so
ah so basically the claim is I'm just
gonna have this set up and for you to
make progress you have to give up a pawn
because if you played well Jeff can also
do this and I got a passport I put a
Pawn on G4 so it lists a bishop or a
king has to be always there protecting
it right and if you ever yourself go B5
I will simply take on C6 so I do think
this end game is more dangerous than it
appears because black does have the
right colored Bishop so you you won't
have the ability as you would in most of
these obstacular Bishop end games to
just sacrifice your Bishop for the uh
the queen Side Pawn because black would
win that end game
wait if I
wait if I give up my well you have to
write Bishop for this one but it's right
oh you have the wrong Bishop for the um
for the agent for both sides yeah yeah
um but okay but this is like very
interesting you know because I'm
attacking G3 so your king cannot move so
I don't know if I go G4 then you take
the engine doesn't care but I would be a
bit scared so maybe I can play Bishop D3
force you to do this yeah the bishop
Bishop C2 now your King is Coming
so what I wanted to do is
it's not what I achieved so how do I
want to make a draw here
um so maybe I need to start pushing my
own Pawns
yeah
why does an even down material here the
only reason why white is worse is
because black has two past pawns and
White currently has only one
yeah no G5 why with whoa the computers
really going crazy there I was gonna say
why is white worse and then it went down
and okay then went back up
okay this would be unfortunate
and but everything we did was uh pretty
logical now so we went what
you can see five so I should not allow
this somehow so what should I do oh I
need to put a king on yeah yeah it was a
nice tempo
if I go here
can I hold a fortress here I think I
think I was gonna say I think so and
then yeah
I don't think I'm holding four first
actually because if you move this way I
go this way
okay I guess I don't go that way
this this game's just very hard to play
wait if I go
but why not
this is probably some kind of uh you
know like a move by move it's um right
ever like well every Temple counts and
somehow
white sleeves let's play some every
position looks like a study yeah
it needs to be far away so you don't
have a temple like if I play Bishop G7
and then you go here and I can
like this looks a bit silly and then you
get six one then my Bishop is always far
away right so Kenny 4 doesn't come with
Tempo and now King B5 is a stronger
version yeah okay
but it's weird that it makes such a big
difference
so all right
[Music]
and if A4 I can
go here and can and if you come with the
king I go here
okay I don't go there
is it easier for you to block my Pawns
I'm also starting to realize that maybe
black shouldn't take
yeah
I think if you go here maybe I have King
G4 right and now actually my pass band
becomes dangerous but if you don't take
it's as you mentioned this one diagonal
rules and from one diagonal I can stop
both Pawns
so I can actually play
um after G5 maybe just King C4
so this is also a mistake everything I
play is a mistake so Kirk objectively is
holding a quarantine engine right now
but definitely he's not out of the woods
I think practically speaking he's going
to need to make a a lot of precise Moves
In order to hold the draw do you want to
take a look around before we sign off
yeah
yeah I think this will be what will this
be yeah I mean this position looks uh a
bit scary for both sides I have to say
but
um our eval you know it's making my
thinking a bit biased but kind of scared
for both Kings
so in this game I think block will
eventually win
I think the position is just too good So
eventually this Pawn will start moving
too and
with the past months I think black will
convert so with between a row for Json
if he Converses I've just heard breaking
news the bach is actually defeated
quesada Perez and we will be trying to
get an interview with him yes and this
is a result we're expecting right so
what happened after King chief wait
after King G4 I think that's where the
game ended and we're expecting this
result so this is two in a row for buck
but if we did Psalm 7 yesterday and
winning this game
with black uh against quesada Perez and
I think this was also probably very good
preparation by him because he played
this line that was played before and
yesterday was he also had very deep
preparation and if we get him we will
also try to take a look at the game from
yesterday
and let's see what else do we have in
group a we had this Christopher you
versus thorough game so Christopher you
is fighting with his um Fortress
so if this is
knighted to a threat every time I try to
pass him over I realized I can I was
like oh let me pass the movement
with this move that I can okay so rookie
3 has to be played
and what is the idea
but I think this position has been like
they were making moves for a while
already because we saw the structure for
several months already
and I think this game this game has to
be over we've had this position for a
long time Mishra versus nishnik
so Christopher versus darawissa Benjamin
book winning some losing two in a row
and uh this position also
will left this
um some time ago right yeah but there
has to be some kind of approxy right I
don't think white is yeah white is
repeating already yeah so
so fun threatening mate so Queen C3 was
played and I
I don't think
white will go for any kind of Adventures
here so I expect a Perpetual in this
game yeah I think you only draw when
it's h and G not when it's uh f and g
and also you never want to go for that
end game even if it is a draw because
we're just playing for two results dude
they're magically hold or you just lose
so that's everything in group a and in
group
in group
so Michael let's give one we saw this
position and Luca versus collected in
this looks very dryish with the opposite
color Bishops
the weaknesses in the position for black
should be able should be very holdable
this Pawn is just holdable and
black can just challenge this rook and
always hold the spawn so this also
should be a draw the interesting game is
this one with the opposite color Bishops
but with this past fonts and
also
uh this one gargle Contour versus Jason
Liang where we expect a
we expect black to eventually convert
and actually Chandra
he did play Rook D5 black hasn't
responded you're telling me King H6 and
we're doing something silly here
apparently that's a huge mistake
wow
so what did we say uh we said Rook G7
but I believe myself Queen D2 yeah but I
see now that you're yeah Queen C6 yeah
would be nice because you don't have a
way to block why can't I block this way
because Rook G7 right yeah
um oh and then the bishop is overworked
because if I go
this way you can either take or just
even have one yeah or F1 Knight even
well yes
yeah now we're wearing a coin oh very
important F1 Knight is like force
Checkmate I think
I think H6 is actually annoying
but what do I play here
so is actually a movie one to play so
what should I do I don't cannot do
something like this
right that would be devastating for
white so what to do
what to do with white
hmm
so I have to say Rook D5 is a really
nice check but a nice move because you
know we had this idea of plugging this
check from the fifth Rank and giving up
this Pawn
maybe we can start with Queen D2 as that
silly Queen D2 with the idea that if you
go over G7 now I play Rook G5
apparently not like that move very very
much oh I understand why I held my I
held my Bishop Queen G6 Queen E4 Queen
C4 oh no yeah that's uh it's an
unfortunate mistake to make
um yeah this is so white has to find a
move so what can we do so Rook G7
so Rook to seven is a huge threat so
white has to do what white has to try to
exchange no but you have Rook G7
and where does my king go I cannot go to
F1
oh this is actually just made
so I have to go I cannot go on the h
this looks very bad oh no actually this
looks okay so I cannot go to H2 because
I get made it so I have to go
somewhere with the king I have to go to
either F3 or H3 but this looks a bit
scary but if we can
force a queen trade so for example and I
now I have Rook F6 checks so for example
if Rook G1 then Rook F6 threatening this
bishop forces in exchange
King comes back
and very simple drum just not enough
pieces left on the board
so Queen fi was actually a nice resource
and actually maybe close to an only move
because this position looks quite
dangerous for white
and King H6 was is on the board and
actually has to find a move to
not be in trouble because as we saw
there are some resources with Queen C6
Rook D7 is a threat and maybe not such a
pleasant position
and our other game with the two with the
opposite color Bishops H5 was played and
actually white did not take white did
not spend time taking on P5 he played H5
immediately so the idea is if takes then
he's not afraid about this extra Pawn
because he thinks the bishop will be
able to stop all these Pawns if the
bishop goes for example if something
like G4
Bishop comes to B1 and from B1 uh as
Julian mentions the one diagonal rule
that Bishop from A2 will stop all the
past Pawns
so maybe taking on P5 as we were
considering was not as necessary
and maybe this is actually simpler and
if before then
the bishop
can come back and here we can actually
build a fortress I believe because King
D6
if I go here I think even this should be
a fortress
F5 and there is no way for black to make
progress anymore because this King B5
move that we're looking at before is no
longer available because of this Pawn on
a force so
taking this B5 then that means was not
necessary it's the only move we consider
it but H5 with the idea of G4 King E4
just creating counter play
by creating a pass Pawn is White's idea
and now black is going to decide if he
pushes or he takes on A4
and we do have a guest with us Benjamin
Bach who won two games in a row
congratulations really nice wins and we
actually wanted to take a look at both
very games because looks like they've
offered the preparations
so let's start with today's game so
let's go through this game and you can
tell us about your preparation and where
it stopped yeah for sure so uh yeah
first of all thank you for having me and
uh yeah so I played yaser Casada
um so he played the real oppressive
which is kind of what I expected and I
hope to surprise him a little bit with
the move A6 because normally I'm more of
a Berlin player but I had already played
the movie 6 against uh Darius in the
tournament but his move Bishop after
Bishop before Knight F6 D3 took me a
little bit by surprise and here I played
the move Bishop to C5 so you think this
is a sign he wasn't expecting you to
play six and then yeah so he still
played uh kind of quickly and also the
move D3 he's really limiting my my
options because for example I can't play
the the open uh real pass anymore and
like all those types of uh of things so
I played Bishop to C5 I thought it's
clever to
a delay B5 for one move and he canceled
I played B5 Bishop D3 D6 and the funny
thing is I actually had this against
Darius in round three via different via
different move order so he played A4 I
feel like okay Rook B8 is the most
logical move he took on B5 takes takes
and in this position Darius played the
move Bishop to E3 and after that I was
quickly fine but I was wondering okay
what do I do I have to remove C3 because
here I have two uh two options I can
either play the move H6 stopping Bishop
to G5 altogether but then I thought okay
what if he goes D4 and he goes into the
main lines and I have this extra move H6
but I don't know how valuable it is I
mean I guess black should be doing quite
fine here because I guess it will come
in useful somehow
um and it's it's actually a little bit
silly because after I played like I was
wondering about this during the game
with Darius and after the game I I
didn't check it well whereas I should
have but I decided just to Castle I
figure like okay you can go Bishop to G5
but I'm I shouldn't be too worried about
it
I go H6 which page four
and here yeah I didn't consider Knight X
G5 very seriously oh really yeah I mean
it very rarely works but I think here
he's got a good version compared to
other like Italian games or because my
knight on C6 is unprotected so he can
always go back to the bishop D5 and it
will be very unpleasant to deal with all
right but this is a bit of a concession
for him already right putting a bishop
here yeah I thought so I thought if he
goes Bishop G3 I have two yeah Bishop G4
is an option uh he plays H3 I guess
maybe bishop H5 he maybe black just has
a very comfortable game here I'd have to
check I was wondering like after Bishop
G3 if I can go G4
um if he goes in that H4 I go Knight H5
and I think black's doing pretty
comfortable but the question is always
like what happens after Bishop H4 yes
it's a question of actually having a
Pawn on H6 is helpful too because you
don't have rights yeah yeah like like
this is a this is a thing in an Italian
game take take King G7 I guess also like
Bishop D5 and these positions are never
easy
and probably he will do the same plan
with D4 and 93. yeah and uh yeah he's
going Knight C2 to E3 and it's very
difficult for me to get out of the the
PIN
um so maybe we have time for them
well we don't because if we go 96 and
he's not a five ah yeah and I mean if I
go C6 there should be three like it's
very difficult
how to get out of this and in the
meantime he's gonna make us like Rook A6
maybe King H1 and try to maybe somehow
get a four in and uh yeah it looks it
looks practically very difficult for for
black so I feel like okay if you guys
right there yeah yeah this is really
interesting right so I figured okay if
he goes Bishop G3 I'll figure out what
to do and then you play Knight X G5
instantly and and I thought to myself
like oh am I getting into some
preparation via different move order but
okay so I have to take he takes and yeah
play King this I was wondering for a
second later like could I have played
the move Bishop to G4
yeah I think tactically the
route but I don't know if this was I
think the queen he won
and
um maybe
because now I might have well Bishop E6
he probably still goes Bishop D5 so it
doesn't change a whole lot it was 25 and
I'm just lost
but here maybe after Queen E1
yeah it it's always so difficult I guess
I stopped to go King G7 he goes Bishop D
no Bishop D5
uh King H1 I guess yeah and yeah four is
coming very yeah and now here the
differences in the game if he goes let's
say instead of Queen F3
so after King G7
uh if yeah queen of three because I
don't have time right yeah so let's say
he goes King H1 instead of Queen F3 then
I can play rocket shade and now F4
there's 94. yeah yeah this is a nice
trick
yep all right so you played Queen F3
okay I figured and here for a moment I
was considering Queen E7 but I thought
that's a queen E7 he goes let's say
um
yeah let's say Bishop bishop or maybe
Queen G3 right away I thought yeah Queen
she's three right away and it didn't
quite see a move
because if I play let's say rocket shade
here he takes an F6 and he goes King H1
and I thought it's just
it looked I mean Rook H6 and Rook G6 oh
wow
it's very
but it's saying taken yeah apparently
taken H4 is winning
oh yeah just
adjustment yeah this is a very funny
configuration of check me
yeah but I did feel like my king of six
can get stuck and then I'll be in
trouble uh so I played Rook dates rookie
shade it looked logical then he played
Bishop D5 okay I have to go Bishop D7 he
played B4 Bishop B6 ready three and here
I've yeah like I thought of some pla
unpleasant if I just sit like I play
Queen E7 Knight C2 so all of this
actually was played before which is why
I thought maybe this was preparation
well I guess it was preparation by him
like I I I didn't know so I feel like
okay let's say I go 98. it looks it
looks very unpleasant because he's going
to go 93. you just don't have moves and
I I don't have moves and I'm just
waiting for something something bad to
happen right and uh
yeah it's very likely right something
that will happen actually maybe she can
get 200 or something on the A5 yeah I
mean perhaps I have to play something
like Rook H6 to I didn't even see a
rocket chick so I was wondering like how
do I even break loose with this it feels
like white is just a better Army making
is still weak he's got two pawns for the
uh two Manor pieces so I play Knight xd5
I thought at least practically this
could change the momentum of the game
because now my moves are a lot easier so
how what did you think about this
position how did you evaluate it
um difficult to say I thought that maybe
objectively he should still be better
but I did think that it was diff it
became a lot easier for me to play now
I'm gonna go Rook H6 bring the other
rook and I start jumping around with the
knights and it's all of a sudden not
that easy for him so he played D4 which
I think is still fine I played Rook H6
so we're looking at D5 here which I
think is a difficult move to play but it
kind of makes your night a bit funny
because if you go to d8 then at least I
would kill him that the road cannot go
here and your knight is bad and maybe at
some point well I I did think that
perhaps at some point he should give
back the exchange on B6 but yeah I found
98 and then F6 Knight F7 and I didn't
think it was so bad to be honest I I
think we're trying something like this
and then we're trying to take and since
you have everything on the seven rank
just to play it with the Tempe yeah I
guess it's a very like it's a very
effective plan to use the AFL to either
like give up the rock for the bishop or
maybe to trade a whole pair of Rooks
because I think of why traits of one
pair of Rooks it's although maybe here
here I'm so fine but yeah they'll
teknown B6 looks looks very strong I
didn't I didn't see that unfortunately
neither did he say plate Queen G3 okay
which is just a voice of attempt or
maybe hit that The Rook on each file is
dangerous so yeah and here I was also
considering the move F5 but I it was
difficult to figure out what's going on
like I thought maybe here he goes for k6
anyway
um yeah it's it's all very very uh
complicated yeah but I thought rookie
trade is okay because at least now a
certain
or sorry what I played in the game
instead
um rocket shade extra Queen E3 right
because now I threaten Bishop H3 and
so he played F4 and okay I took him D4
and uh yeah now it's all becoming very
loose for him so he took with the Knight
we just yeah I didn't even see it was a
move I thought initially if he takes the
Knight I go Rook H3 and it just
collapses right away but I miss that he
has to move G3 oh good okay because if
you move to the queen I take on C3 and
he just loses right away but oh yeah
that's nice
yeah
um so I thought Knight xd4 was actually
a clever move but it turned out to be a
big mistake I uh if he was gonna if he
would take with the pawn I was gonna
play at five anyway because I have to
stop at five from him and now I get some
scratch for my pieces in the center and
probably he again has to go for
something like Rook A6 because my Bishop
B6 will always be super strong but I
thought okay I take an E4 it takes takes
similar to what happened in the game
right no I don't have a phone yeah I
thought like what he did was actually
clever because the defi I mean maybe
yeah I don't
is pretty safe like I have a lot of
pieces around Knight F6 then here I'm
trying not to blunder a queen yeah I
mean maybe if white plays really well
it's still okay but black speed black
Smooths are a lot easier so he took with
the Knight it's just interesting because
it feels like this Knight is very bad
but yeah once we trade this night it's
just so much easier for you yeah it
makes a lot of sense to trade of the the
knights and I guess the real problem is
just the move that he missed so because
normally it makes sense to trade off
some pieces when you have the queen
versus uh the pieces because then the
queen becomes stronger but yeah he just
missed this line so I played at five
Rook A6 and now I think he completely
overlooked Bishop C6 and the point is
that if he takes on B6
I take an E4
and he's just uh he's just busted so I
think well and then the idea is used to
you're just dominating well the thing is
like I don't have to recapture on B6
right away because if I recaptch from B6
he goes D5 and then he's doing pretty
like on the last move
uh no instead of verse 64 because
Mission like I said I tend to take a
beat yeah if I take them D5 he's doing
well but yeah if this little intermat
Super 64 and I threatened pretty much
Checkmate on G2 so then you win Rook F3
which I thought was a clever try to at
least trade off the pair of Rook so hero
is also considering pawntix E4 but the
lines get very messy I thought he goes
like rocktex B6
and uh if I take it to Palm okay so here
you cannot take that hand so yeah I
would take I thought maybe a five and I
have Rook G2
but after Rook G2 maybe even like King
F1 and it all get I mean I don't know if
this works maybe this is not good but
but it all gets super messy and I was
getting along time and I feel like okay
we're 64. at least I keep it somewhat
more taken
yeah even even all of this is all is all
a mess yeah like
so I think what I did was correct I took
the bishop he played Rook G3 trading on
pair of rocks I play Knight E5 take take
Queen E2 and I thought here Rook H4 was
a good move because I take the pawn on
F4 which is very awkward to defend
because if he goes G3 I thought I was
gonna go Rook H3 and I don't see what
he's gonna do against Knight F6 to G4
and uh pretty much any end game is
always winning for me so at some point
he has to go for some sort of Rook takes
B6 and hope for some counter play
um
so I took the pawn I don't know if it's
correct but yeah my thought I thought
okay it like I won this like yeah I can
take with the knife but my knight often
once I head back to D5 anyway but I
guess it makes sense to keep the
structure intact because after CB air
thing gets kind of weak
um but yeah perhaps this this was better
than I can have the C4 so I took the
pawn but they just have such domination
with all your pieces and then you walk
back with the Rook that's very nice Rook
d8
Knight F6 I feel like okay I can give up
the b-pawns but I want to hang on to the
d-pawn as long as possible because if he
takes that one then he's starting to
create real threats
so he took Rook C8 and then he and then
G4 I think was just a losing move but
it's already very difficult uh because
here yeah after 1940s all of a sudden in
a mating that end the nice thing is that
he doesn't have any checks yeah I think
it's still 785 which is really funny
yeah and then we saw the rest of the
game which was you just win and of
course King G4 you're not wasting time
with 95 and very straight actually with
the into the end of the game yeah the of
course the the critical line was instead
of let's say
um like after king of five it's a king
g45 king of five if he goes King D4
Virgo Knight D7 and there's no way for
him to come break through because if he
goes these sex ago King E6
and let's say he goes skinny three back
or like after 97
so King E3 here then I just go King F6
King E7 King D6 and then Knight F6 and I
I ran up like all the spawns are just
stuck so when I saw that I I knew the
win uh
um also in my pocket yeah yeah this
this is a just uh keeping the king out
which is the spawn structure in the
night was quite beautiful for you so
so King D4 and then
we saw another version of this in the
game yep then you just keep this up and
come and take and actually we really
wanted to take a look at your game
yesterday because
um that one was let me find it very
quickly so that was round five and
so this one had to be all preparation
right because he had a game from last
year's um American Cup yeah so he added
that he had that game against Ray Robson
and I had prepared it all the way uh so
yeah F5 uh King E3 E5 this was all the
game that he had against uh Ray
and um right or or was King 3 was not a
new move yet right uh so the way I have
to do it
right so so G4 was it was a novelty and
the point is he can't really take on G4
because if he takes circle king E4 and
this becomes very dangerous I go King D5
and he can't stop my king from getting
in so G6 is correct
I take take and I play F4 and maybe
black can hold this end game but it's
always super unpleasant for example I
mean he can't play E4 really because
then I go King D4 my king marches in
again so he played 96 which was the
first new move to me and
um so what had you analyzed here so I
had looked at uh king of seven and then
I take an E5 again he takes it a knight
and yeah something like king of four why
does white is better and it's always
kind of unpleasant for black but with
perfect play Black should hold but I
thought okay I have no risk here I can
just push for for the win and um yeah he
also had a long game the day before
against Darius so if you're like okay if
I can
it won't be unpleasant again for him to
to defend so he played 96 which was
which was the first new one for me so I
figured okay I have to take an E5 it's
the only move he takes and here I was
considering to muscles looking at Knight
D4 but I also thought I can play Maybe
H3 first but the drawback of H3 it has
some 94 but the drawback of H3 is and
now he goes B5
and if I go Knight D4 he goes Knight C4
check King D3 95
yes B4
so so with B5 he places the pawn on the
on the right square and it also can go
Knight D4 anymore so then the question
becomes okay how do I make progress so I
figure 94 is the best move and maybe
incredibly the move F4 might already be
losing I had a look yesterday maybe he
has to go Knight G4 but it's all super
unpleasant I go King D3
um let's say he takes on D4 I recapture
Knight X H2 I figured at the very least
I have like King E5 or maybe I can go
after B6 spawn again I think this has
already lost for him too yeah I believe
so so I think this position is already
very bad for him yeah so he played F4
kicking E4 only move he takes I take he
goes F3 only move like I have to take
take and here I think King D5 and King
C4 pretty much the same thing now he has
to take an H2 because otherwise maybe I
just keep the spawn on the board and so
yeah here I figured okay I just have to
go after the pawn with the with the King
and here
um initially I thought king of was a
mistake
so I thought maybe he had to go Knight
F3
I take him B6 and he has to try to stop
my Apon somehow so maybe 94 with the
idea that if I go A4 he has an ib3 and
it's very difficult to get rid of that
Knight and I think it's just it's just a
drone
right so I looked at Bishop B3 then I
thought okay he goes Knight C2
and I thought okay Bishop C5 but then I
wasn't quite sure today after Knight A1
because now again if I go A4 he goes and
ib3 so it's kind of it's kind of crazy
but maybe I still win with something
like Bishop D4 Knight C2 and so it's
actually interesting it says there
because that's it too
but then also in 93
I'm probably looking
fine but then it's taking too much time
and he can bring the king I feel
yeah I've been very helpful I have to
say so 91 1 maybe bishop D4 Bishop
Knight C2 and Bishop B2
and yeah the great thing is like it
always just takes me one move to stop
respawn and in the meantime his Knight
is always going to jump around and the
funny thing is like in many of these
positions like let's say he um
he can he can go for that rotation right
with the Knight like very often you go
like um uh let's say 97 CA D6 to B5 but
the thing is let's say I have my Bishop
on H2 then I cut the then I saw the pawn
and I cut the D6 Square so those end
games are always lost so did you think
here already when you reach this
position did you think are winning here
I I wasn't 100 sure I thought again I
thought his best try was Knight F3 and
then he played King of seven I thought I
should be winning but okay so I have to
think I'm B6 it goes King E6 and here I
was calculating for the longest time but
fortunately I had an hour and I thought
initially it was a draw and I was
looking like okay maybe I um to play
something like Bishop for first
um but okay he goes like Knight G4 or or
maybe Knight F3 and yeah the drawback is
like if I don't push my Pawn right away
I might give him extra options
like here yeah A4 maybe he just goes
King this yeah he goes King D7 let's say
A5 and then Knight E4
A6 Knight C6 and I I don't see a single
still a single uh zuk Zone here
uh but he just let's say goes H5
when we make all these moves but the
thing is he always has 97.
right and I go King B7 he has 98 or 95
so there's just no no zooks long like I
think without the H Pawn I can go King
B7 and Bishop C7 but uh now he just
pushed the pawn H3 and never go Bishop
C7 he goes 95 and if I take the H2 so
there's uh there's just no zuzong here
um so yeah I was thinking for the
longest time here and then all of a
sudden I saw this line so A4 King D7 A5
King C8 uh Bishop four and I figure like
okay he has to go in ig4 because if he
goes Knight F3 I go a six and he he
always has to try to check me on the D5
square like let's say he goes Knight D2
here I go A6 and Knight C4 King A6 and
he runs out of checks
so 94 is the only move
A6 and here I was thinking like okay if
he goes Knight F6 I was very happy to
see King C6 and I thought like okay I'm
winning
but then I saw this move 93
and I was like what do I do because
obviously I cannot so 93 is an easy move
to miss from afar because it looks
impossible but of course I can never
take the Knight because then he goes
into the corner
and the thing is I cannot play A7 but
because then he goes Knight D5 and he
keeps checking me he really needs the B4
Square yeah the whole idea is this yeah
and uh and then I figure like okay if I
can
um
yeah at some point
I like I thought it's just a drop
because I thought okay you can go to F5
and you can go to E7 and very often it's
a clever ID to put my Bishop on D6 right
but I thought if I boom additional D6 he
goes Knight to five attacks my Bishop I
have to move it again and then he goes
to E7 but then I saw okay if he goes
tonight if with my Bishop D6 if he goes
Knight F5 I can go King B6 and if he
takes A7 so then I had this idea of this
this one so I played King C6 Knight F5
Bishop D6 97 so obviously I can take
King C5 and uh yeah this is basically
the first zoo and he cannot move his
Knight because if he goes Knight F5 I go
King B6
and uh I go yeah he takes A7 and Knight
C4 and King E6 and it all just works out
so he has to start pushing the h-bomb
and yeah it's really nice that my Bishop
is covering the H2 Square so I played
Bishop H2 this is like a cosplay on
study yeah
it's really incredible it feels like my
game was a was a study yeah like after
F4 you have to basically see this whole
idea so yeah bishop g397 and again the
Windows 9 goes to E7 I go Bishop D6 yeah
when we got to this first position with
the pawn on 87 we figured you already
saw the zuk zavang and you're just gonna
keep repeating until his point is on H3
and he runs out of moves because it
feels yeah you already figured out the
configuration here I had I had figured
it out yeah uh so H4 I move and then
yeah the important thing is wish for
four uh not to go up with page two
because then he goes Knight G3 so he
weighs Bishop D6 again I wait which for
4.93 and also the nine on E3 I go Bishop
to D6 and Knight C2 and yeah King B5 was
the last important move to to see
because if I go King C6 he goes H2
both moves
oh yeah
yeah and now right now I even lose
um and if I go King B6 let's say after
uh then he goes H2 and it's also a draw
because I have to take and he goes
Knight B4 and he keeps checking me idea
yeah
and here I actually also has this move
well this I don't think so this is
necessary though yeah because I I go
like Bishop D6 and then along my king
over to A6 right right okay that is
unnecessary but okay yeah we can just
keep checking yep
um but yeah King B5 I I thought it's
like the last final touch and now
um 93 he goes King C6
H3 gives up the pawn so it's the same
position 56 yeah and here after King C5
we finally have the the ultimate zooks
one he cannot make a move because after
nine to five King B6 takes A7 Knight C4
King A6 I just get the queen and the
rest was all pretty easy so yeah it was
a very
um satisfying uh Victory like I I yeah I
never thought I would play like well
first of all I think it was just a
perfect game and second of all I think I
pretty much created a study yeah yeah
that was a really beautiful game we were
watching it I mean of course we have
this uh database that tells us the
results so it's easier for us but it was
really nice configuration and we're
actually wondering if uh you because you
didn't think until move I don't know
like 30 something like around here this
was your first thing so we thought this
was all preparation oh it was a nice 94
94 was my first thing okay because 96
was a new move for me
and um okay so 96 I thought for two
minutes but I feel like fxc5 is the only
move and here of course I had to to to
think and I of course like after Knight
xc5 I cannot calculate all the
variations till the end but of course I
saw this line like he takes upon an H2 I
go to the problem B6 and it all looks
unpleasant like it's almost impossible
to calculate it to the win and I think
Sam told me during the game that
um I don't know when uh like the moment
he played I think when he played Knight
X H2 he might have still thought it was
a draw but he was thinking for a long
time about the move king of seven
and yes we played all of this quickly
because he has to take
yeah so it takes an H2 King C6 and I
think here he thought for a while yeah
he thought for a while about king of
seven and I think also about the move
skinny six and he told me after the game
that he already realized it was lost
because yeah of course with black you're
super weird so of course he's trying to
find the best moves for me but yeah
already he uh he didn't see a defense
and uh yeah he also felt like okay like
I have an hour to figure it figure it
out so yeah eventually I yeah it took me
a long time but eventually I I saw hey
maybe I can put him in some like this
yeah this wasn't no this was an amazing
game or we didn't see it until the very
end we just saw when we figured you're
gonna be winning so congratulations on
both of your victories yeah thank you
uh very um you know must feel good to
win this game yesterday like this and
today's game was also fascinating that
the imbalance of Converses so
congratulations and good luck in the
rest of your games
and thank you to Benjamin for this
interview and we will take a look at the
standings as we do have a lot of results
coming in so let's start with group a
where Benjamin actually takes the lead a
half a point ahead of a pack of players
elenijnick Benjamin glidera and Daniel
TARTA and Dario said Christopher you are
still playing and we expect that game uh
to end in a dress we would actually if
that happens we will have a three-way
tie and in group b we have Jason Liang
in who won his game with four points
leading the tournament and he's half a
point ahead of Victor michalevsky who
also won his game and as well as Felix
and aksha Chandra who are playing each
other so it's possible that both Felix
and akshard will join Jason in the lead
for first place
so that was a very educational interview
with Benjamin Buck who is very gracious
of him to come in and share his thoughts
about both of his games yeah he seems to
be in a really good mood winning two
games somewhere else I think we got him
on the best day possible so it was
really nice to hear his thoughts about
this game yesterday and today's game of
that they're very fascinating Quinn
versus three pieces and of course
yesterday study like game which I think
you know is going to be one of his best
games probably in his collection we'll
go down in history oh yeah for sure
um be sure to join us tomorrow at uh oh
Wednesday there will be a event with
varakovian on Bobby Fischer at the World
Chess Hall of Fame so be sure to check
that out on the world chest Hall World
Chess Hall of fame's YouTube channel
foreign
so join us tomorrow
at 3 P.M Central Standard time we will
have more 4 P.M Central Standard time
we'll have more coverage of the uh 2023
uh spring chess classic
oh my God
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited